everybody's lined up at the box office
for the sneak preview of stab but they
all have the special sneak preview
tickets so by the far they standing in
line at the box office they have an
usher standing outside the box office oh
why can't she just take the tickets some
dumb ass white movie about some dumb ass
white girls that's racist yes both
saundra Bullock is Miss ethnicity right
I'm going to thank all my reps for
giving us Miss Congeniality three years
later and they have another usher taking
the tickets that you get when you
exchange the sneak preview tickets to
the box office the runs this theater
probably 75% of the movie theater
managers I worked with I'd like to add
that despite having roughly 500
employees outside to do menial tasks
like Usher who stands in front of the
box office and person who gives studio
swag to customers and three dickheads in
charge of Ghostface puppets and this can
guy they have zero security in this
mother only in a Hollywood version of a
film sneak preview would there be this
kind of chaos plus this is a movie
within a movie based on a real-life
event where real people were murdered so
this theater crowd is a bigger bag of
dicks than a bag of dicks
also with the real-life event aspect in
mind that the studio really find it
appropriate to give away costumes based
on the ghost face killer and the fake
knives if you went to a premiere of a
movie about John Wayne Gacy I don't
think they'd be handing out clown makeup
having clowns float above you during the
movie wait a minute this bathtub made of
bricks is there a potted plant next to
the shower maybe this movie is merely
suggesting there's nudity on screen but
the way this was shot in frame the
nudity is a lot got I love those showers
with a big huge window next to it for
whenever you're hosting peeping toms
while I admire the spirit of this
totally out of control sneak preview
crowd there was no way these people
would be wearing their masks while
watching the movie these assholes can't
see a goddamn thing
haha how are they able to get the actual
Ghostface voice did the police ever
record phone calls in the first movie
look I know that stab is a satirical
look at the original screen but this
Casey Becker heard her phone ring when
she was about to take a shower and went
to answer it but in the meantime she
also had popcorn popping this reminds me
of that old camp slogan you can't shower
and pop at the same time there were
really too many slogans about showering
and popping so even though everyone in
the theater has been making all kinds of
noise since the movie started Maureen's
outburst crosses the line you may not
have heard a company man there but he's
all excited that they're sold out by the
movie despite the fact that studios give
out an overabundance of free tickets for
sneak previews so you didn't sell out
face no matter how much you want to
impress the usher girl by the way
despite a total sellout of seats and
every seat is currently filled there are
still people coming in late for this
movie this is the most exaggerated movie
theater scene in history until
inglorious basterds comes along Jada
Pinkett and omar epps stand here talking
in front of the auditorium for nearly a
full minute and are not crushed by
people going to concessions or the
bathroom
considering the wild crowd this movie is
showing us that's impossible so
Ghostface know exactly where Phil's ear
was gonna be on the other side of the
bathroom stall also since we find out
later Phil was an intended victim then
how did Ghostface know that Phil would
be in the adjoining stall at this time
or that the urinals would be taken
Ghostface could not event in the
bathroom after Phil because he's clearly
already in the other stall I totally get
that there are a bunch of people dressed
up like ghosts face that have a bunch of
times but how in the hell did no one in
the surrounding area see Maureen get
stabbed even if you thought somehow a
knife going into a body was faked there
would still be some sort of reaction
also lucky for Ghostface that the studio
sent the costumes and a ton of people
chose to wear them for the sneak preview
because if that didn't happen I'm not
sure how the killer's plan works for
getting the actual stabbing that's going
on right now I don't think even 20-year
old me would have ever gone to a movie
with this much bullsh going on during it
this is the dumbest audience ever to
watch a movie not call jackass this self
induced isolation you got going it's not
healthy I mean you just lost a lot of
your friends to a couple of crazy
killers who you then had to murder one
of which was your boyfriend is everyone
a dick in this movie
you could say what happened in that
theater is a direct result of the movie
itself this teacher feels like it's a
good idea to start discussing a new
story that just broke about some fellow
students that got murdered and turned it
into some sort of philosophical debate
on how film can turn people into
murderers or some sort of bull by
definition alone they're inferior films
a definition of a sequel is that it's
the next chapter in a series of films it
does not define quality as that is hard
for a definition to do aliens is a
classic okay get away from her you bitch
I believe the line is stay away from you
bitch it's film class a film class where
no one knows that Randy is in fact wrong
in Joshua Jackson's quote was correct T
- you've got a hard-on for Cameron and
CC he has a problem paying attention
because Mickey was not the one who
mentioned aliens meet Derek he's the
kind of guy who hops the railing to make
a direct beeline to his girlfriend
rather than using them much easier
stairs like a normal person
I'm local wait I shot - bingo finals
Gale weathers who has a best-selling
book and a hit movie made out of that
book and only get a cameraman who shot
the bingo finals so I get that there
would be a press conference but would
they have that press conference on the
college campus the kids weren't murdered
on the campus it seems like a very
convoluted way to get Sidney and Gayle
to meet up early in the movie even if
the story broke earlier the previous
evening how quickly could do we get on a
flight and get there by the next morning
well I was hoping I might get just a few
words with you after the events of the
first movie Gail actually thinks she can
get away with sandbagging Sidney and not
get punched or slapped
see see casually answers the call
waiting after having her life threatened
so CeCe's on campus if the sorority
houses are on campus then why would you
need a sober sister one of the many
moments in this movie where the killer
catches a lucky break in their plant who
enters a room like this good thing Cece
left that door open and the killer now
knows that Cece has a troublesome
boyfriend both this and the theater
murder have relied on a lot of
coincidences that goat-face could not a
note about for everything to go
according to plan
also movie gives away the fact that
there has to be at least two killers
since the one in the background of this
scene clearly doesn't have a phone oh it
sounds like the guy on the other end of
the line has cruel intentions for Daphne
the Vampire Slayer and a simply
irresistible grudge because he knows
what she did last summer and something
something Harvard man somehow Ghostface
goes from five feet behind Cece to an
entire hallways length between shots
what a soul who parks their bike three
stories high in a goddamn sorority house
I get that Cece was just trying to run
away from the killer but how was her
strategy gonna pan out was she gonna
jump from the balcony and not once when
she has the chance does she close the
door behind her and try to lock it this
was pretty much Sarah Michelle Gellar's
movie career in 1997 getting stabbed by
the killer I think it even happened in
Beverly Hills Family Robinson
why does Sydney feel the need to answer
this phone at a sorority she's not even
a part of and never will be the killer
somehow managed to lock the door from
the inside in a way that it could not be
unlocked to get that's some crazy
so as Ghostface trying to kill sit here
because based on what we find out later
on in this movie that makes zero sense
this asshole runs inside the sorority
house and leaves his girlfriend outside
alone and while I admire his need to
beat the feather killer
I can't believe a protective boyfriend
would just leave his girlfriend outside
when he doesn't even know what the
situation is anyway exactly because he's
totally the killer right Derek's actions
in this movie are more like make me a
suspect than anything that makes sense
as well as a boyfriend Steven North
Stevens Marie Nevins Maureen Prescott at
Sydney's mother I don't think this ever
gets developed then it turns out to be
bullshit anyway
but what are the odds of this this
killer finds a couple who have the same
or similar names to the first two
victims of the Woodsboro murders then
kills a third person who just happened
to have the same name as the third
victim it's a total red herring but it's
some incredible bullsh if it wasn't on
purpose do you think someone's trying to
duplicate woods proof
I think after questions like this do we
has no reason to question anything gail
writes about him in a book think you
have a copycat on your hands gee if this
wasn't obvious after the first three
people were murdered and Sidney was
chased around by someone in a Ghostface
costume trying to kill her also why is
Gail even here maybe they would let
Dewey in since he was a cop on the
original case Gail is still a reporter
it hasn't exactly proven herself to be
trustworthy the director said let's have
your character start the scene carrying
an apple in his mouth it'll make him
look even more like the obvious killer
of this movie and an asshole also notice
how derek is eating a green apple
Mick he eats a red one yep they're both
equally assholes just once a killer
result Tom Cruise Top Gun 1986 you know
what makes the film nerds in these
movies so pay annoying naming the actor
the movie and the year during a movie
reference movie has time for this also
this is cute and all but wouldn't SIDS
bodyguards be at least a little on alert
here this seems like the definition of a
distraction
kudos to scream - for making Sydney's
joke prediction from the first movie
come true that Tori Spelling would play
her in the movie about her but even in
the 90s can you name one movie where
Tori Spelling would have been given the
lead in any major film who discovers
that her boyfriend's this crazy serial
killer
god damn Tori spoiler alert how would
they know this scene even happened there
is even bay
very similar dialogue Gale weathers was
not present for this and based on their
relationship or lack of one I'm not
guessing Sydney let Gayle in on any of
these moments my mom left my dad I
accepted it that's holy this Luke Wilson
take on the Billy Loomis character is
being priceless the guy's pre-med miss
pity me service won't conveniently
missed every major vein and artery so
you think it's Derek
now do he is taking opinions from a
college kid film nerd seriously he might
be the worst cop ever first of all he
wasn't got it I made that up
slash why would you change that detail I
need you I cannot do this without you
not trying to belittle camera person's
job but would it really be that hard for
Gail to find another person to fill in
for Joel Cassandra's wanted to great
tragic visions of literature it's just
me but I don't remember this time
wasting both first movie she saw it all
coming the wars murder
Jesus this movie is on some serious
foreshadowing overload in this scene
with all its going on it's totally
asinine that the drama teacher would put
her in a scene which is basically
repeatedly being stabbed by mask
strangers hey guys
you think maybe all the knives and
stabbing motions of this production
could be affecting Sydney in some way
yeah she's just crazy Bert
you know I'm gonna go ahead and give the
movie at least once in for not making
these two the killers The Killers trying
to finish what was started this is a
very good point that Randy is making and
by the end of the film this is clearly
the motive which begs the question why
the hell were the first three people
killed and how did the killer's even
know if anyone would figure out the
first three victims were tied to the
previous victims especially since it was
such a loose threat okay so what do you
want to do bonehead I just want to sit
here and wait and see who drops next
well I don't know bonehead what do you
want me to say I don't know just keep
him talking
come on you yeah let's split up because
that's never been a bad idea in a horror
movie and Randy should know better also
why don't Randy Gail and do we have
police protection as well they also
survived the Woodsboro murders am i
close
Randy has conveniently jumpscared by
random people that have nothing to do
with his current predicament
The Killers plan if Randy had chosen a
walk with the phone in the opposite
direction like I said earlier these
characters literally walk into their
murders this is pretty close to the
employee who wears headphones at work
and doesn't hear the violent stroke only
possibly more infuriating you have an
instant master says I'll just hit him
hilarious 90s computer lingo damn dude
he said hit em not QWERTY or whatever
you just typed
worst bodyguard ever did cata know
Sidney was standing right here he's not
the killer and he's not Yoda so but also
why did he decide that the library was
the time to approach Sidney about being
on TV with him and why is he being so
creepy remember when Gale sandbags
Sidney earlier even he looked shocked
but Gale would stoop so low so now he's
an asshole stalker just to add him to
the list of suspects we've issued a
campus lock in this evening no one's
allowed out after dark okay if Sidney's
being taken somewhere else the she care
if people aren't allowed out of their
dorms after dark then potty my van is
now an official crime scene thanks to
you um because the killer opened your
unlocked van and used it to kill Randy
it's Gail's fault if the killer really
is watching and relishing every minute
that he'd be here on these tapes right
so let's go use the school's facilities
to watch these tapes after hours instead
of going to your television affiliate
and watching them by the way it was
totally day time when they decided to
watch these tapes and now it's totally
nighttime because I guess this campus is
vast there's no way that Joel shot his
footage using regular ass VHS tapes
brumbley used Betamax or some sort of
totally not VHS tape because VHS is not
what you would use for broadcast quality
even if your main claim to fame is the
bingo finals is it possible to meet you
a second time scream two delves into the
hot topic I have no interest in Galen do
we are watching recording of the
previous day's press conference but in
the earlier scene in the movie where we
see this press conference there is an
entirely different guy standing next to
Hartley we're looking for the killer who
might be on this very tape let's I
should be studying
the shot of omar epps and Jada Pinkett
suggests that the killer shot this
footage from a parked car on the side of
the street but I remember that scene
vividly because in the establishing shot
I noted that there were no cars parked
on the side of the street I know what
you're thinking maybe they're on the
other side of the street but then the
person operating the camera couldn't get
audio this crisp so let me get this
straight
somebody probably Mickey decided to edit
all his stalker footage together just in
case Kalyan Dewey came here tonight to
watch their footage why is the first
instinct here to find the first room you
can hide in why is getting the god of
the air not the first thought and it
looks like there's an exit at the end of
this hallway but it's being obscured by
the fact that this is a horror movie and
lack of reason and logic this is a very
cool set piece but why is there our maze
of soundproof waling and even if that is
a common occurrence in sound studios how
does gayle end up in the one room that
has a series of items she can hide
behind while the killer is stalking her
I mean she could have just as easily
trapped herself in a janitor's closet so
the killer didn't hear that no lock on
the door so why is she not dead I'm her
therapist Hallie and Sid share the same
room and would have been getting packed
together
furthermore Hallie said at the police
station she was coming with Sid so I'm
not sure why the cops are on edge when
Hallie comes out and she has to explain
herself and the cops didn't even flinch
when they saw Derek creepily waiting
outside for them this is all over
so be here I get this has nothing to do
with ghosts face and is some frat bull
but everyone has to know what killer is
walking around dressed up and hacking up
people the chief even instituted a
curfew for the campus so why the what
anyone dress up as anything and hide in
the shadows Don't Ask Don't Tell
apparently the security detail was going
so slow the killer was able to follow
them and keep up with them on foot until
they stopped at a traffic light either
Mickey or Debbie salt just killed a
trained detective was able to basically
climb in one motion on top of the car
and is able to pull off a nifty kick to
another trained detective I don't think
Mickey or Debbie fit the Jackie Chan
mold but here we are also if I haven't
said how much these cops sucked before I
will now because these cops suck just
shoot his ass
yes it's a cop car but the killer was
able to punch his way through a window a
minute ago why can't you guys kick the
window out movies keep trying to sell us
on the idea that a killer can regain
consciousness and exit a car without
anyone hearing or seeing anything even
though they were only 20 feet away he's
gone what remember the situation they
were in
they couldn't even open the door on the
passenger side they were in such tight
quarters as he runs after Sydney look at
the obstacles he had to navigate here a
wall that completely blocks him from
running anywhere but the goddamn street
where Sydney and how he would have seen
him I found GUI why are you on campus
right now cotton is not the killer folks
no matter how much the movie tries to
put him in situations that make no sense
for ass character to be unless he was
the killer I almost got killed
where should I run got it I'll go to the
theater it's brimming with cops
I mean props this is someone who's at
least a second year drama student who
can help me so did the frat asshats just
leave Derrick here knock him unconscious
and duct tape his mouth yet another
convenient chain of events for ghost
face does the killer actually have to do
any of his or her own work in this movie
surprise so wait a minute was the plan
to unmask and explain all the motives to
Sidney how many times because she had
died in this movie does the knife do
from this distance you have a gun
remember Loomis Sidney recognizes her
immediately but yet somehow never saw
her the many times she was roaming
around campus Deb there my backer I met
on the Internet psycho website
classifieds the actual story of how
these two teamed up together is way more
interesting than the punchline this
movie explains it away with I think it's
either dumb luck or impossible once
again why are we talking so much I'm not
trying to kill Sidney like you did
thirty minutes into the movie my motive
isn't as 90s as Mickey's mine is just
good old-fashioned revenge oh you did
you really have to go through with all
of this to get Sidney back and now I
kill you and I can't think of anything
more rational
never gonna get away with this you're
right so instead of killing you right
now let me explain to you how I'm gonna
get away with this and by the way is
campus security on holiday or something
wasn't there a curfew everything's
traceable back to Makia including the
cop gun he used to kill everybody except
for all the people that weren't killed
with a gun you're as crazy as your son
was what did you just say by the way not
that this couldn't happen but it seems
strange to me that mrs. Loomis gives
this much of a fighter son her husband
cheated on her and yet she's the one who
needed to leave she couldn't get custody
of her son kind of reasoning is this
there's no way she cares this much about
her son if she abandoned him in the
first place
sure let's just chalk it up to her being
crazy but I'm not buying it wait are
these like real rocks not staged rocks
I guess they teach method at this school
you mean Sydney ran into this room and
didn't immediately exit this place she
knows there's an exit back here god damn
it this isn't a surprise for fuck's sake
don't you move cotton ex machina also I
was caught in here why would it have
occurred to him to go to the theater the
last time we saw him he was at the film
school making Gail think it was the
killer so naturally he wanted her on
campus for 15 minutes and ended up here
if Sydney didn't get shot then why not
because she pretending that she did do
you feel the effects by osmosis or
something for the press State hey this
is Gail who was alive does this you
didn't want to say help or something I
always come back how many times does
this motherf ER get shot it was three
times by my count even if he's alive how
can he shoot up like this when he has
virtually no blood left I'm back I don't
blame Joel for coming back after all
that's gone down but why would Gail
allow him back here Stewie alive after
eight hours of unconsciousness with
major stab wounds the paramedics say
something like the knife winning is some
old scar tissue and saved his life but
doesn't blood loss count for something
and so every reporter leaves Sydney
despite the fact that they try to
interview her all the time for whatever
the reason
[Music]
don't let the happy 90 sound up
collective soul fool you
everyone Sydney was friends with and the
first and second movies are dead now who
does she have do we the drama teacher by
next week he's one of the bad guys in
Titanic so not him either so I take
umbrage with this happy ending I found
that can hand and I put it in a pot of
boiling water and get some Kong it soup
hot ham water I mean look at you you
already got hurt just a flesh wound
just keep him on the phone what do you
want me to say here's the plan Sawyer
[Music]
might have gotten away with a toe it
wasn't for these blasted kids in their
dog